We're back with our mindful man, Jay Shetty.
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
Now, you are the chief purpose officer at Calm and you know
a thing or two about being calm.
And I wanted to ask you a few stories that we wanted to run
by you and ask, does this make Jay Shetty calm?
Are you ready?
All right, let's try it.
All right.
The New York Times reports a group of 20 moms gathered
on a football field in Boston recently
to scream their faces off.
These ladies spent 24 minutes just letting it rip,
screaming out their frustration, pain, rage.
Does primal screaming make Jay Shetty calm?
Well, my wife and I recently, we went to a rage room,
which is the room where they give you baseball bats
and wrenches, and you get to break stuff,
old stuff that doesn't belong to anyone, obviously.
And we're breaking it, and it was really interesting
because we went in not stressed,
we came out more stressed.
Really?
So if you're going to
try something like this, you have to actually be
feeling some stress or pain to try it out.
I think it does work.
I'm not much of a screamer, me personally.
I don't know, whenever I feel rage,
I just eat like, cheese puffs and do online shopping.
That's all I do.
And that gets it out.
Maybe I'll try screaming.
Well, what about this one.
CNN reports the university of Leeds found
a scientific study that said watching cute animals
can actually reduce anxiety.
They had people watch 30 minutes of baby animals like
oh, puppies and kittens, and guess what?
Their blood pressure went down, their heart rate went down,
their anxiety dropped, and we actually showed a clip
last week that I can't stop watching.
Drew, do you remember the foxes that were giggling?
Yes, it's my favorite thing ever.
It's my favorite thing.
We have it, can we roll that fox giggle?
Oh, you have it?
Yes, watch this.
(foxes giggling)
Oh wow, that's adorable.
Okay, come on, now that's got, I'm no scientist
but that's gotta make us calm, right?
I mean, that's beautiful.
I'm one of these people that, I scour Instagram
and social media looking for clips just like that
because they bring so much joy to my life.
I mean, look at that, that is just,
that's adorable, I love that.
All right, stamp of approval?
Yes, 100%.
And finally, some turn to self care to find
their meditative moment, and People reports that
the latest hydrating skin mask is a slice of baloney.
Okay.
I'm just, it's baloney, it's not real baloney.
I'm trying to say, oh, that's baloney, as in it's not real,
but it looks like it is.
So this is face mask that looks like a baloney when it's,
you guys, look it, look at this.
And here is the good news, is that it actually was made
by a very good K-Beauty company,
and when it comes to skincare and innovation,
I find that that's very, very important.
It's made by Seoul Mamas, as in Seoul,
like, Seoul, Korea.
It's really cold. (Ross laughs)
I, what do you think, Jay Shetty?
I mean, you both look great.
Jay Shetty, does this make you calm?
(crowd laughs)
(Jay laughs)
Yeah, yeah, I guess so.
What about when I do this?
(Jay laughs)
Yeah, blow it.
That was brilliant.
That's a great party trick.
This is, if you're just tuning in, hello. (laughing)
Okay.
Calmer or creepy?
Calm or ham?
Calm and creepy, both.
Exactly.
Oh, don't breathe in, look.
(crowd laughs)
I just have to say, I am so excited that you would come
on this show, and I think what you have put out
into the world is so important, and you've become this
trusted figure that we can go to and find ways to
figure out how to have a life that is meaningful.
And I just can't tell you how much
I respect and appreciate you, and need you in this world.
Thank you for being giving, and thank you for coming here.
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
That is so beautiful.
I'm just, thank you.
Jay Shetty everybody, live in person.
We'll be right back.
(upbeat music)